damit kriegt
also haben wir ein neues bücherregal ein
neues t-shirt und damit werden wir uns
heute am tanz moralphilosophie wenden
könnte die grundthese von kamps
moralphilosophie kurz erklären also das
grundprinzip von cannes zum rad
philosophie der kategorie winter hat
fakt der kategorische imperativ sehr
komplizierte formel dazu handle so dass
maxime deines willens jederzeit zugleich
als prinzip einer allgemeinen
gesetzgebung gehen könnte natürlich sehr
lang hat und darin befinden sich viele
begriffe die mit erst erklären müssen
am wichtigsten ist die griff die maxime
ist was könnte märklin seien für mich
werden maxime sogar die prinzipien da
lach ich haben wir auf die bänke
berechtige
genau das meint auch aktiven sind die
prinzipien unserer handlung unsere
subjektive meinungen sagt ja die
subjektiven wilms meinungen die sollen
wir eben nach dem kategorischen
imperativ prüfen soll also überlegen
können wir diese wieder ins meinungen
diese maximen können wir die prinzipien
widerspruchsfrei verallgemeinern würde
sich daraus ein wieder hergeben wenn
jeder so handeln würde
die maximierte dies wenn die 1000 wieder
spiele geben würde dann wäre diese
maxime oder auch böse um rad sogar lösen
wir hätten wir ja ein beispiel mit dem
depositum genau es gibt also ein ganz
bekanntes beispiel das kann anführt um
diesen markt im test zu erläutern
depositum entgegen stand die man sich
weit und jetzt gleich mit
die tafel die position der begehrteste
position sagt ich nehme etwas von dir
und ich glaube es dir aber auch wieder
zurück und widerspruch werde sich dann
ergeben wenn ich
dieses standbein würden versprechen
würden wieder zurückzugeben
aber insgeheim darauf hoffen würde
dadurch irgendwann mal vergisst und dann
gesagt würde dann geb ich dir eben nicht
mehr zurück es gibt jetzt natürlich
zurück in sein widerspruch er dann und
halten wenig mehr gibt
rading begriff also sinngemäß verbinden
in der kommunikation mit ihren anderen
begriff davon mache nämlich dem dienen
würde
das würde nach kann dazu führen dass der
begriff das depositum sich selbst
aufheben würde
okay das theater selbst die würden über
werbung bleiben aber jeder inhaber der
größte position würde widersprüchlich
verwendet werden und das böse zungen
widerspruch in eine maschine führen dass
werden und das könnte auch eine böse
ahnung
genau diese insofern als ich eben eine
falsche ein falsches versprechen machen
das wäre damit zitiert das ist eben
nicht mehr zu geben und wieder
einzuführen
moralisch als ihr meine privatinteressen
stelle setzen dass es nach ganz
untypischer fall des bösen geben auch in
anderen sendungen hätten wir etwas über
das thema des bösen was wir da eine gute
handlung gute handlung wäre zunächst mal
auf jeden fall eine handlung die
widerspruchsfrist also eine maxime die
sich für allgemein und ist daher wäre
aber verkannt allein noch nicht
hinreichend eine gute handlung ich
könnte ja zum handeln dass es passieren
konnte dass aber das motiv was da in der
lage sein
ist uns angst entdeckt werden also angst
wirken das kann kein richtiges moralisch
muss also so handeln dass meine maxime
wieder und es muss noch zusätzlich ein
motiv hinzu kommen ein besonderes
moralisch motiv das kann die acht und
das moralische gefühle achtung die
achtung vor dem vierten gesetz das
untypisch weil man normalerweise würde
man klage die achtung gilt der person zb
die tiere kann zeigt die achtung muss in
erster linie die noch an schon gesetzt
dem kategorischen imperativ gelten also
eine beispiel nur zuschauer
die achtung von obdachlosen wird im
ganzen leben beider arme greifen wird
nicht der fall von dem die achtung vor
dem genau der moral dass man das
grundsätzlich meinung genau als ich
könnte da in der folge dem obdachlosen
geld geben arbeiten an erster stelle
müsste die achtung vor dem kippen gesetz
alternativen zwischen chinesischen und
epischer fall der alternative ist der
tourismus der tourismus sagt gut das
wenige was die meisten nutzen mit sich
bringt diejenige handlung die für die
meisten die größten und schlecht oder
böse eben diejenigen die den geringsten
nutzen von grafischer gegenpol zu kampf
der er sagt das komplett auf die
handlung als muss kommt auf das motive
an dass die handlung zugrunde geht um
das mit einem beispiel abzuschließen
könnten wir auf das mit dem zug und dem
gleis und den leuten die auf dem reifen
zurückgreifen also da mein zug der fährt
dann gibt es fünf personen die sterben
würden würde man schranke nicht
umstellen und auf der anderen auf dem
anderen gleis berger einen platz
da was würde dort werden die tourismus
sagen was viel kampf und elitär ismus
würde sich fragen was bringt den größten
nutzen
in diesem fall wie ich empfange
überleben die meisten menschen würde
irgendwann sagen die
ich muss so gestellt werden damit am
wenigsten menschen stehe also über eine
person ist im extremfall keine
militärische theorie würde das heute
netzwerk zu sagen artikel fall würde das
so aussehen während kann würde sagen
dieses ganze szenario ist an sich schon
unmoralisch warum wir das leben eines
menschen auf wegen und anton leben
sie behandelte den menschen an sich
selbst die cantus fordert ein gewisses
mittel mit dem wir formulieren können
eine kalkulation anstellen können dass
wir dafür könnte das liebliche das geht
auf keinen fall